[Müzik]
selamlar
İzmir'den tedx Bursa sahnesine gelinceye
kadar farkındalıklarla dolu 25.000
kilometrelik
serüvenimin 18 dakikaya sağın bölümünü
sizlere aktarmak istiyorum
Öncelikle bir baba sonra Nadir
hastalıklardan biri olan Kistik hibrozis
hastalığının İzmir'i il temsilcisi
Türkiye'yi temsilcisi Hatta dünya
temsilcisi diyebilirsiniz bana evet
dünya temsilcisi Çünkü hala Bu hastalık
yüzünden yüz binlerce çocuk her gün
hayata veda ediyor Bizim Hikayemiz
bundan 18 yıl önceye dayalı Evet evladım
Fatih'i kucağıma aldığımızda Nadir
hastalıklardan biri olan Kistik hibrozis
ile tanışacağımız Aklımızın ucundan bile
geçmezdi Evet oğlumuz kistik fibrozis
hastalığı ile dünyaya gelmişti Peki
Neydi bu ki hastalığı
doğumdan itibaren gelen karaciğer
akciğer Pankreas ve tüm dış salgı
bezlerinin Tabiri caizse dışarıya deli
gibi tuz ve kloru atması bu tuz ve Klor
bizim için hayati önem taşıyan akciğer
karaciğer Pankreas ve bütün dış salgı
bezlerinin iflasına sebep oluyor ve
tanısı konulmazsa erken yaşta
çocuklarımız hayata veda ediyordu Evet
oğlun ki hastalığı ile dünyaya gelmişti
5 yıl 9 Eylül Üniversitesi'nde Yattık
Bir taraftan anne babanın travması bir
taraftan evladınızın o damar Yolları
bulunma aşamasındaki acısı
sıkıntıları 5 yıl
5 yıl sonunda
yine arayışlarımız devam ediyor O
hastane senin bu hastane benim derken
yine 9 Eylül Üniversitesi'nden çok
değerli bir hocamız ismini almadan
geçemeyeceğim Profesör Doktor Aynen şu
sözü söyledi Gökhan bey ülkemizde Nadir
hastalıklı genetik hastalıklarla ilgili
yeteri kadar çalışmaya yapılmıyor
Çocuğunuz için yapmanız gereken sadece
iki şey var Birincisi seril bir ortam
İkincisi ise spor Evet evimiz masumlar
Apartmanı dolapları açtığınızda her
tarafta dezenfektanlar tuvalet kağıtları
peçeteler Evet eşim
üzerine düşen görevi fazlasıyla yerine
getirdi kendisini minnetle buradan
selamlıyorum
sonrasında spor Evet oğlunuz için
yapacağımız iki şeyden Diğeri ise spordu
Evet 5 yılın sonunda oğlumu evimize
yakın bir yerde bir jimnastik salonuna
yazdırdım oğlumuz da orada
Arkadaşlarıyla beraber akciğer
fonksiyonlarını geliştirmeye çalışırken
ben de artık sıkılmış yan tarafta
büyükler için açılmış spor salonunda
ufak ufak spor yapıyorum
sonra 3 değerle arkadaşla tanıştım Murat
Çakar Murat tanınmış ve kir çakaroğlu ve
Zafer mutlu Onlar kendi markaları için
Türkiye'nin farklı lokasyonlarında
markalarını tanıtmak için koşarken Artık
benim de bir markam vardı kistik
fibrozis derneğimizde tanışmıştım
Derneğimizin sloganı erken tanı Hayat
uzatır erken tanı ve tedavi merkezleri
istiyoruz Evet tişörtünün bastırdım bir
branda
Evet erken tanıdığım için çok önemliydi
ve
yarışlarımız başlıyor
ilk yarışım Çanakkale Gelibolu maratonu
profesyonel bir sporcu değilim Normalde
maraton 2,5 Saat 3 buçuk saat arasında
biterken Ben beş buçuk saatte maratonu
bitirmiştim 5 buçuk saat ilk önce
yarışın en ön safhasında yer alırken
brandalarımı ve tişörtümü insanlara
gösteriyor sergiliyor farkındalık
oluşturmaya çalışıyordum düşünün ilk
çıktığınız maratonda en öndesiniz ve beş
buçuk saat sürüyor maratonun en sonunda
bitiriyorum başarısız olduğumu
düşünmeyin Bu beş buçuk saat boyunca
yanımdan kaç sporcu geçerse kendimi
onlara aktarmaya çalışıyor ki
farkındalık oluşturmaya çalışıyordum
endişelenmiş eşim beş buçuk saat sonunda
o geniz aksiyon yetkililerini ayağa
kaldırmış eşim gelmedi eşim gelmedi
acaba yolda bir yerde düştü mü sonra
ilerden ben geliyorum tişörtüm sloganım
var ama yan taraflar kırmızı kırmızı Kan
İzleri sanki Çanakkale Gelibolu
maratonunda ben
resmen savaşmıştım ama o esnada
algılamıyorsunuz sonradan öğrendim
koşucular göğüs bandı takarlarmış
sürtünmeden dolayı tişörtüm kan olmuş
onu da öğrendim bu benim için bir
farkındalıktı evet
Dernek yetkililerimiz Her zaman der ki
bakın Sizler sosyal medyada dijital
platformlarda boy gösterirseniz bizim
elimiz daha güçlü olur kanun koyuculara
gittiğimiz zaman bir kamuoyu oluştururuz
Evet kamuoyu oluşturmaya başlamıştık
gördüğünüz gibi
bayrak bayrak gazetelerde
televizyonlarda Kistik hidrolikle ilgili
haberler çıkmaya başladı
nasılsınız
bir mağaranın içerisinde bir örümceğin
önündeki taşı alıp kaldırmak Onun için
bir iyilik yapmak o mağaranın
duvarlarından çıkar evrende dolaşır ve
Size bir iyilik olarak bir güzellik
olarak geri dönerdi Ben hep bu
felsefeyle hayatta kaldım ve doğaya
evrene hep mesaj vermek istedim
ama
mesajı bu şekilde büyük bir balonla
görünsün istedim uçan bir balonla Evet
uçağın bir balonla evrene vermek istedim
balonun üzerinde Aynen şu sözler pislik
bir rojistik erken tanı Hayat uzanır
erken tanı ve tedavi merkezleri
istiyoruz
bu koşumda Evet uçağın bir balonla
koşmak Gerçekten zormuş 42 kilometre
bayağı zorlu bir koşudan sonra yüzlerce
evladımızın dileklerin yazdığı balonları
uçurduk balonların üzerine tek şey neydi
biliyor musunuz rahat bir nefes almak
yaşamak istiyorum Evet evrene güzel
mesajlar veriyorduk ve backgroundları
2015 yılında bize Geri dönmeye
başlamıştı
Nadir hastalıklardan biri olan bu Kistik
ibraziz tanınmıyordu bilinmiyordu ama
2015'te yapmış olduğumuz çalışmalar
Derneğimizin içerisindeki yetkililerin
bakanlıklarımızı sağlık yetkilerimizi
sürekli kapısını aşındırmalarıyla artık
bütün çocuklarımız pislik idiolojisi
olarak tanınır hale geldi topuk kanından
alınan küçük bir örnekle bütün
çocuklarımız artık tanınıyordu Evet
çalışmalarımız yerini ulaşıyordu bir
şeyler oluyordu İzmir'in Kemalpaşa
ilçesinin ufak bir köyünde ikamet
ediyorum
evlatımız Yan komşumuzun kümesindeki
hayvanları ilgi duymaya başladı ve bir
baktık tavuk üreticisi olduk Çok özel
tavuklar beslemeye başladık işte Bravo
değişik değişik köy tavukları oğlum
internete giriyor sağda solda nerede
böyle değişik güzel tavuklar var
Onlardan sipariş veriyor
bir gün bizim kümese bir fare dadanmış
bu tavuğumuzun ayağını kemirmiş ve ayak
yok ortada düşünün 10 yaşında ve Oğlum
bizden habersiz bu tavuğun yara olan
bölümünü bir iğne iplikle alıp dikmiş
düşünün 10 yaşında bir çocuk
bunun farkında her canlının yaşaması
gerekliliğinin farkında ve ona dokunmuş
Evet ona dokunmuş
bizlik gibi bu his hastalarının
Akciğerle alakalı çok büyük sıkıntıları
var bizim için organ bağışı çok önemli
Evet ben de ne yapabilirim dedim gittim
sıra dışı bir şey yapacağız ya yine
Kasaptan karaciğer akciğer kalp çok
attım bunları Avrasya maratonuna
gidiyorum şeffaf bir çanta yaptım
Türkiye'de kaç tane akciğer hastamız var
bekleniyorsunuz işte 2500 adet akciğer
hastamız var 1500 adet karaciğer
hastamız var 1000 adet kalp bekleyen
hastamız var Evet 42 kilometre bu
organlarla koştum
Yine ses getirmiştik gazetelerde
televizyonlarda organlarla organ bağışla
destek vermek için koştu sloganlarıyla
bu sefer bu göstermiştik medyada dijital
platform bizim işimize yarıyor ve
kamuoyu oluşturuyorduk artık bir değil
10 değil binler olmuştuk
Hani konfüçyüs'ün bir hikayesi var ağzı
bir kavanoz var ve içerisinde bir elma
var bütün öğrencilerine Söyler bu elmayı
kim çıkartırsa o elmayı onun hak
edeceğinden bahseder öğrencileri tek tek
dener elmayı çıkartmaya çalışırlar ama
kavanozun ağzı çok dar olduğu için
elleri sıkışı ve bırakmak zorunda
kalırlar
Biz de aynen o şekildeyiz elmayı
tutuyoruz tam çıkaracakken gücümüz
yetmiyor ve bırakıyoruz bu gücü sizlere
Bizler kazandıracaksınız Konfüçyüs geri
adım atıyor kavanoza alıyor ters
çeviriyor ve elma avucuna düşüyor Biz de
bu elmayı Eminim Eminim sizlerle beraber
bu çocuklarımıza yedireceğiz sonra kendi
kendime dedim ki Ben dedim sınırlarım
aşmam gerekiyor Ne yapayım
İzmir'den Samsun'a koşmadım çok güçlü
sponsorlar buldum düşünün bir Kemalpaşa
İzmir'i Kemalpaşa ilçesinde köyündesiniz
Gece yarılarına kadar sponsor aramakla
meşgulüm hastalığımızın Acaba nasıl en
güzel şekilde tanıtımını yapabilir evet
sosyal platformlarda dijital
platformlarda boy göstermelerine sebep
olabilirdim Evet 100 sponsorluğa 10
günde İzmir'den Samsun'a pislik gibi
çocuklarımızın farkındalığı için pedal
bastım muhteşem bir organizasyondu 10
gün boyunca durmadan pedal bastık yol
üzerinde nerede sağlık ocağı var Aile
hekimlerimizde bir araya geldik
kendinizi aktarmaya çalıştık nerede
üniversite öğrencilerimiz var Özellikle
tıp fakültesinde okuyan öğrencilerimize
bir araya geldik onlara durumumuzla
ilgili farkındalık oluşturmaya çalıştık
dönem ödevi olarak
çocuklarımıza kistik fibrozis
hastalığını vereceğiz Evet yarının
Anneleri
öğretmenleri doktorları sağlık memurları
daha 16 yaşında 15 yaşındayken Kistik
hibrozisle ilgili farkındalık içerisine
girmişler O konu hakkında araştırma
yapıp artık deneyim kazanmışlardı
muhteşem muhteşem muhteşem geri dönüşler
alıyorduk bizim için çok özeldi Evet
ardından
evrene dedik ki
canımız çok acıyor o kadar çok acıyor ki
evlatlarımızı
nasıl söyleyebilirim diye düşündüm ve
bir tabut yaptırdım ölçüleri tamdı tam
bir çocuğun yatabileceği ölçüde
kilometrelik maratonda omzunuzda bir
tabutla koşuyorsunuz
tabut ölüm
Biz çocuklarımızın ölmesini istemiyorduk
ama evrene bu mesajı vermemiz
gerekiyordu algılanmak Fark edilmek
istiyorduk Evet Evren bizim sesimizi
duymuştu Türkiye'den çok uzak noktalarda
Evet Türkiye'den çok uzak noktalarda
bir yerde Birileri bir çalışma yapmış ve
hastalığımızın tedavisi bulunmuştu
ama Türkiye Türkiye maalesef Nadir
hastalıklarla ilgili yeteri kadar
çalışmayı yapmıyordu bizim çocuklarımız
hala ölmeye devam ediyordu ama orada
birileri bir çalışma yapıyordu ve
ilacımız çıkmıştı
yıllık 300 bin dolar
Evet çocuğumuz yaşatmak için 300 bin
dolara ihtiyacımız vardı güçlü bir
devlettik ama farkında değildi
varlığımızı Devletimiz şu anda sizlerle
beraber devletimizin bizim farkında
davalarımızı açtık ilaçlarımızda şu anda
200 hasta olarak kavuşuyoruz ama
Türkiye'de 20.000 hastamız var amacımız
bu 20.000 hastaya da hiç davalar
açılmadan ilaçlarını kavuşturabilmek
Evet
artık
yaşayabiliyoruz Ama bu bize yetmez
20.000 hastamıza dokunmamız gerekiyor
Aslında bugün sizlere aktarmak istediğim
olayların farkında olmanız
Evet farkındalık bir ateş gibidir Bir
şeyi fark ettiğiniz zaman başka şeyleri
de fark etmeye başlıyorsunuz kadını
çocuğu hayvanı daha duyarlı oluyorsunuz
ve fark ettiğiniz şeylere dokunmak
istiyorsunuz dokunduğunuz anda
gördüğünüz karşılık Evet o sizi mutlu
ediyor
bir söz var Normal olduğunuzu düşünüp
Mutlu olabiliyorsanız
muhteşem olabileceğinizi düşünüp
Aslında doğamızda bizim
muhteşemlik yatıyor normallik Yatmıyor
lütfen hepiniz anormal olun sağlıkla
olun mutlu olun teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]